I have to say you threw everyone into
quite the frenzy with your new Instagram
there's like a wolf type there's the
wolf tattoo is for a new movie it's not
real it's not real no it's not real I'm
the hair is fake everything's fake will
do blondes have more fun
once well I'm naturally I am a blonde
but not this blonde but I can assure you
blondes do have more fun yeah as you
know I Taylor back hurry had a good time
as a redhead you're going back soon then
to the red hair I am I am season 7 is
coming up it kind of left us with like
this crazy crazy cliffhanger possibly
alluding to something about jon snow's
heritage do you know anything well I
think living is fairly safe to assume
that jon is no longer what is what no
longer he was never a stark and is
pretty much Targaryen it'll be very
interesting to see how their
relationship developed Sansa and Jon's
especially now her knowing that he's not
stark be very interesting I loved seeing
Santa's arc this past season I feel
Shirley grew into her own what was it
like for you as an actress it was
everything I'd hoped her character would
develop into it felt very empowering to
be able to do that and play such a
strong character and it was great having
my first kill as well that was a good
one what do you hope to see for Sansa
next season dwindling down to the end I
know we're dwindling down to the end I
mean my true hope so that she reunites
with her family and what I kind of hope
she goes a bit sadistic as well just for
you know work point of view it would be
very fun to play a sadistic kind of
character but we'll see